- [Prof. Shore] Thank you all for coming,
I'm very happy to see you.
I am delighted to be introducing
my colleague from Ukraine,
her name is Oksana Mikheieva,
who has come here from the
other side of the ocean,
despite difficult circumstances.
She comes to us originally from Donetsk,
but in the meantime from the
Ukrainian Catholic University
in Lviv and from the European University
in Viadrina in Germany.
She is a historian and a sociologist
who combines those methods in her work.
She has been working now
and for the past several years,
or at least since we met
in Vienna a few years ago,
on this issue of refugees
and internally displaced persons.
I think most of you may know,
and Jenu is not in the room
otherwise he should really
introduce this topic.
So when the war in the
Donbas began in 2014,
it created a situation
in which not only were
people being slaughtered
and, even before this
full scale invasion began,
some 15,000 people had died?
I may have that number wrong.
And between a million and a half
and 2 million internally
displaced persons.
And that's a category
that refers to people
who became refugees in their own country.
So domestic refugees, so
Ukrainian residents of the Donbas,
this post-industrial mining region
in the far east of Ukraine
where the war was concentrated,
who were forced to flee their homes
and go into other parts of Ukraine.
So it's conceptually, politically,
legally, sociologically,
you know, it's a very
interesting situation,
It's a very painful situation,
It's a kind of agonizing situation
and Oksana has been quite heroic
in both being a participant
and observer in those events
and continuing her research
despite the most gruesome circumstances.
I will not take up any more of her time.
I just wanted to give those of you
who don't work on Ukraine in particular,
that context of internally
displaced persons,
'cause I know a lot of you have experience
thinking about and working with refugees
and what does it mean
when you have refugees
who are in their own country,
but they are homeless and displaced.
What does that mean
for their legal status?
And what does that mean for their lives?
With that, I will turn you
over to Professor Mikheieva
and thank you so much for coming!
- Thank you very much
for this introductions,
and first of all, I would like to say that
I am grateful for the
opportunity to be here.
It is a privilege to be in this wonderful
and safe place at a time
when people in Ukraine
are living under full-scale
Russian aggression.
Today I will talk about ordinary people
under extreme life conditions
and, my main focus was internal,
and thank you very much
for this introduction.
I really talk about refugees
in their own country
it's a very good formula
to describe this situation,
but we are talk about
internally displaced person
in this case, and little bit I say about
external forced migration from Ukraine
in this time from war torn
territories in Ukraine,
and what is very important to me
and to start with you to talk about this,
that in my presentation
I will talk about the experience
of forced displacement
of residents from the war
torn territories of Ukraine
after 2014, and before
the start of full scale
aggression against Ukraine on
the 24th of February, 2022.
So important for me because
now we have a complete period.
It's one stage.
It's one stage which have a date of start
and date of the end.
We are talking about this period
and try to understand what
lessons we have from this time.
What took place in
Ukraine from Spring 2014
to 24 February 2022
can today be classified
as the first phase of Russian aggression
against the Ukraine.
The outbreak of full-scale
war marked the beginning
of a radically new phase
which entailed a number
changes in Ukraine.
The other very important point for me
because we see how these runs
push Ukrainian society to
do something absolutely new.
However, these changes largely took shape
and manifested themselves
during this first
phase of Russian aggression.
What are the main developments
and trends I'm referring to?
While in 2014 we spoke
cautiously about the formation
of a political Ukrainian nation,
today Ukrainians, as a political nation,
are showing themselves quite clearly.
My separate research devoted
to study this dynamic
of Ukrainian national identity
and I see this process as
it's really very complicated
process for many Ukrainians
because on the one hand,
we see how people step-by-step
create this modern concept of nation
which are based on citizen,
person holding citizenship.
But, this understanding of citizenship
still very problematic
from the point of view
of current situation in Ukraine,
but is separate topic,
very interesting topic.
And, we try to study this element
of citizenship from the point of view
of ordinary citizenship
from the hierarchical citizenship,
from the emotional
citizenship (indistinct),
all of these give us a very
interesting information
how it really,
is now in Ukraine.
The country is experiencing
rapid Ukrainianisation
even by ear, the Ukrainian
language is perceived
not only as a language of communication
but also as a way of distancing
and protecting oneself from the aggressor.
It's absolutely new
function of the language
in the country.
According to the latest results of surveys
by the Kyiv International
Institute of Sociology,
so maybe you noticed that
usually it's very good
the Sociology Institute in the Ukraine,
despite the horrors of this war,
70% of Ukrainians are
hopeful about the future
and it's absolutely incredible results.
The next important moment, Euromaidan.
And first wave of Russian
aggression was indeed
a very strong catalyst for
volunteerism in Ukraine.
If before that participation
in civic organization
for a long period of time
was kept on the level of 11 to 14%,
today we see a completely
different situation.
According to the survey conducted
by sociological group Rating,
in March 2022, more
than 80% of respondents
indicated that they help
to defend Ukraine in one
form or another, 80%.
39% help people and
the army as volunteers,
37% help financially,
18% take part in informational resistance,
12% continue working in
the critical infrastructure
and only 19% of these
respondents indicated
that they did not have the opportunity
to participate in volunteer activities.
There are slightly more
elderly people in this group
but even in this group
there are many people who participate
in volunteering activities.
It would seem that we now have everything
that 30 years of Ukrainian
Independence have discussed.
But what is experience behind it?
All this marks the situation in Ukraine
during and after Euromaidan
and in the time of the first period
of Russian aggression against Ukraine
from 2014 to 2022 extremely
important to study,
and now I start my presentation!
(audience laughs)
(Oksana speaks indistinctly)
One second, mhm!
On this slide you can see titles of,
and very brief information
about our main service in this time.
As you can see it's
really, many of research.
I will not describe all
these studies in detail
because we have no time for this,
only the one important moment.
We have had the opportunity
to collect data,
every year, from the
beginning, from 2014 to 2018.
In most cases it was
a qualitative methods.
We conducted in-depth interview
with different group of
people affected by the war.
Let me start our conversation
about displacement
by giving a little context.
From the 20th of February 2014
to the 24th of February 2022,
as I says before, it's
dates of the first period
of Russian aggression against Ukraine.
Within this wave of Russian aggression
we see two separate cases
that differ significantly.
First the "soft" also called "bloodless",
without use weapon, occupation
of Crimean Peninsula
subsequently led to its annexation
and incorporation into
the Russian Federation
as a separate federal district.
In this case, we have 6 killed people
and 10 disappear.
And second, the Russian invasion
of parts of Donetsk and
Luhansk region, accompanied
by simulated internal civil
conflict and referendums.
Why is so important now?
Because now we see the
repeating of such technology
in Ukraine, but in other
occupied territories.
All of this led to formation
of quasi-state entities
so called "Donetsk People's Republic"
and "Luhansk People's
Republic" on these territories.
Terminology is other issue,
very important and I hope,
after my presentation,
we come back to all of
these terms which are used.
From my point of view it's very
big issue for all researchers.
For example, if you conduct research
and involves your participants
which are representatives
from the both side of the conflict,
it's very important to have
a good language setting,
how to talk with people,
what terminology to use.
It's absolutely impossible
to talk with people
who live on the premium
controlled territory
using, for example, "DPR",
"LPR", et cetera, et cetera.
It's absolutely impossible
to talk with people
who live on occupied territory
using this terminology
"occupied territory"
and why it's a very big
issue for researcher
how to prepare these tools,
which are very different,
and how to combine them, this information,
and make a conclusion if you
ask about something different,
because these people live
in different reality.
But, then...
Well, I go back to this second case.
In this case, as you can see
we have, so many victims here.
It's near 44,000 or more than
44,000 losses recorded at all.
As you can see,
of those, more than 13,000 killed
and, more than 30,000 wounded
23, 25% of this losses were civilians.
We usually have a problem miscalculating
the number of victims
in this case and we
still have this problem,
why we are using the different number
when we talk about the situation,
well it describes the situation.
As you can see on the next slide,
most civilian deaths
occurred in 2014-2015,
during the active phase of hostilities
in Donetsk and Luhansk oblast.
This scheme clearly
illustrates the dubiousness
of Russian theses about
the need to protect
the so-called "People of Donbas"
It's next very important
combination of words
which have very important sounds.
It's a part of Russian propaganda
and they try to construct this community,
"People of Donbas",
such a community has
never existed in Ukraine;
moreover, at the level of ordinary people,
we have recorded active
attempt to deconstruct
this cliche of Russian propaganda,
in many of our interviews.
But let's come back to this
necessity to understand
the specifics of forced
displacement in this stage
and the differences in the
conditions of forced migration
from Crimea and the occupied parts
of Donetsk and Luhansk oblast.
In this so called "bloodless" occupation
of Crimean Peninsula,
people faced pressure,
a threat primarily because of
their pro-Ukrainian stance.
The wide range of discriminatory practices
applied to people who had
pro-Ukrainian positions
caused their relocation.
The residents of Donetsk
and Luhansk regions
fled the war.
The forced relocation was
caused by a direct threat
to their life during the
deployment of military action,
it's a very big difference
with these two contacts.
Accordingly, they had
very different perception
of the situation, and did not always
have a pro-Ukrainian stance.
What the problem of perception of this
to do in Ukrainian society,
but not only this,
a very important role
played as state rhetoric.
What I mean,
in Ukraine this situation
before they issued the law
in 2018 about this situation.
We call this situation officially
"Anti-terroristic operation".
Only after 2018 we start talking
about war and occupation.
It's very important for
understanding this context
because people who are
internally displaced person
have not a clear statuses and
have no clear understanding
from why they come to
other part of the country,
et cetera, et cetera.
In the following slide, you can see
the dynamic of registered IDPS in Ukraine
before the outbreak of full-scale war.
To show you this dynamic,
I have used a good visualization
from the publication
linked to on the slide.
But in Ukraine, all this
data is public and available
on website of Ministry of
Social Policy of Ukraine;
however colleagues have
visualized this dynamic
in very good way.
We see that the number of
registered IDPS in Ukraine
remains relatively stable.
Just higher in allocation.
Compared to 2015, the active combat phase,
in the following years
we see a slight decrease
in the number of registered IDPs,
and there are various
reasons behind these decrease
in number of the IDP.
First of all is natural
deaths of many people
because, many people of retirement age,
elderly people who,
push to flow because of the war.
Then it's purchase of private flats,
in Ukraine, it's very important
moment, in Ukraine people,
in this case, get a new registration
and lose their IDP status.
Then, it's fictitious
IDP have been removed
from the database after
series of state checks,
which removed some part of the IDPs
and some IDPs continued their displacement
and left for other countries,
and some people have
returned to the occupied
territories because of financial
difficulties in Ukraine,
mainly due to problems with renting
accommodation and employment.
It's a very crucial
combination for many IDPs
because, for renting the
house you need to have a work.
If you haven't work you'll have
not money for renting houses
and this combination was very important
for many people when they decide
to return to the occupied territory.
And there is another important
point for understanding
the scale of internal displacement.
During our first interview in 2014-2015,
we identified that up to
one-third IDP are avoiding
official registration for various reasons.
These practices was more pronounced among
young IDPs, who described their motives
for avoiding registration
as both reluctance
to pass on their problems to the state,
and a desire to avoid stigmatization.
And among the wealthier part of IDPs,
who were able to quickly purchase housing
in the controlled part of Ukraine
and change their registration.
On this slide, on the map to the left,
yeah.
You can see the location of
officially registered IDPs
before the full-scale Russian aggression.
As you can see, most
of the displaced person
tried to settle close to their homes,
in the occupied territory.
Donetsk and Luhansk oblast were leaders
in the number of IDPs.
The large number of IDPs in Kyiv
was due to Kyiv's attractiveness
for IDPs as a capital,
where all the key state
structures are located.
The choice in favor of
Kyiv was rationally based
on the fact that it put IDPs close
to the governmental structures
providing assistance.
This shortened the distance
and accelerated the process
of solving many problems.
And then you see another line of regions,
here on this map, it's
Kharkiv, Dnipro, and Zaporozhye
which are also located
in the eastern and
south-eastern part of Ukraine.
In this case, people who
have been been affected
by the war could resettle in territories
that remained under the control
of the Ukrainian government,
and as close as possible
to where they used to live.
At the moment very important
for many of these people
is mostly Russian speaking regions.
On the right-hand side of the
slide you see a visualization
of displacement taking place in the face
of full-scale Russian aggression in 2022.
The situation is radically different.
Most of the IDPs have
tried to move as far away
from the armed conflict zone as possible.
See this difference between
these two situation,
between these two maps.
Another interesting detail become apparent
if we look at the settlement map of IDPs
in terms of their
socio-demographic parameters.
In 2015, the United Nation
High Commission for Refugees
published a map, showing not
only the total number of IDPs
by oblast, but also the
data on the proportion
of different groups of forced migrants
such as pensioners, working age adults,
children, and disabled.
Here, too, we see an interesting pattern.
Among those registered
as close as possible
to the dividing line, pensioners
are the most numerous.
This is another manifestation
of the problem of counting
the real number of IDPs
in Ukraine after starting
the first wave of Russian
aggression in 2014.
A significant number of
pensioners registered close
to the demarcation line
spent most of their time
in their homes in the occupied territory,
due to financial difficulties
and the absence of a systematic
policy of state support.
They came to Ukraine to undergo
identification procedure,
which remained compulsory
and regular every few months,
for pensioner before the pandemic.
The situation changed dramatically
with the onset of the COVID-19 pandemic.
While before the
pandemic, there were about
a million monthly crossing
in both direction,
very good sources,
where, it's a good app which show you,
in the dynamic of this data.
While before the
pandemic, there were about
a million monthly crossing
in both directions,
with the April 2020 restrictions
on crossing at checkpoints,
the number of monthly
crossings fell to 2,000
and was no longer back
to the previous level
until the full-scale Russian invasion.
And, these facts demonstrate
the problematic nature
of counting the actual
number of IDPs, as
registration does not always
indicate a person's actual presence
in the territory controlled
by Ukrainian government.
And on this slide,
you see the main vectors of
external forced migration
from Ukraine after the start
of Russian aggression in 2014.
The key problem with
external migration was,
that in most cases, Ukrainians
left as labor migrants.
The countries of arrival
did not grant refugee
status in most cases,
as a small part of the
territory of Ukraine
was covered by the war,
it was the main argument.
And Ukrainians themselves
have not sought refugee status
because of significant
restrictions on employment.
And now I, want to share
some of our ideas with which
found during our interviews,
in depth interviews with people.
But before I start
talking about some groups
of displaced population,
I wanted to come back
to this whole picture
which give us opportunity
with what happened
in Ukraine on this stage.
In World Migration report, 2020,
Ukraine mentioned in the
list of top 20 countries
with the largest stock of
internally displaced persons
by conflict and violence
at the end of 2018.
With the beginning of
Russian aggression in 2014,
more than 2 million people have left
the uncontrolled
territories of the Ukraine,
and were forced to move both
to other parts of Ukraine
and beyond its borders.
According to the Ministry
of Social Policy,
after 2015 and before the
full-scale Russian invasion,
the number of registered
internally displaced person
was relatively stable
at around 1.5 million.
Residents of war-torn territories
have also been fleeing the country,
or other countries since 2014.
As of December 2015,
in the countries that have
common borders with Ukraine,
such as Russia, Belarus, Poland,
Slovakia, Hungary, Moldova,
there were more than,
it's near 400,000
Ukrainians seeking refuges,
and more than 700,000
Ukrainians seeking other forms
of legal stay in the mentioned countries.
The estimated population
of the occupied territories
of Donetsk and Luhansk
regions is 3.7 million.
These are mostly people
who formally remain the
citizens of Ukraine as a group.
It's very important group of information
which have not enough
attention in many researchers
and in many policies, state policies.
Since 2014, in all our
research we have focused
on different groups of
people affected by the war.
These include, first of all,
internally displaced persons
with their own strategies
of migration and adaptation;
external migrants who were
forced to move by the war;
people residing in the
occupied territories,
who are witnessing a transformation
of their everyday lives;
and residents of so-called gray zone,
the territory between
the two conflict parties,
beyond their jurisdictions,
and therefore, where no one
was responsible for the lives
and wellbeing of people
who lived here today.
In all these cases, the
focus was on the people
whose life-worlds have been ruined,
and who have found themselves
in extreme circumstances of war,
forced migration, and/or under occupation.
Together, all of these
studies could be referred to
as "the average person's life
under extreme circumstances".
In the context of all this our research,
a range of social phenomena arise,
which deserve careful attention
since they concern the recognition
of people's rights to
full life and protection.
These social phenomena
include stigmatization,
social exclusion, social deprivation,
discrimination and practices of othering.
People residing in the
territories engulfed by the war
in 2014 received no
support from the government
at the beginning of the military conflict.
A very small number of
people were evacuated,
mostly by volunteer groups.
Another important point in the perception
of forced displacement was that IDPs,
in the context of Ukrainian state policy,
were and are perceived
as a homogeneous group.
However, this vision of IDPs
does not respond to the needs,
motivations and behaviors of
different segments of IDPs,
and we try to segment this group,
and look at different
segments of this big group
which are absolutely not homogenous.
In all reports on the
situation of IDPs in Ukraine,
the group of people of retirement
age, that's one segment,
receives an enormous amount of attention,
that's absolutely right.
The payment of pensions has
been and remains problematic.
In the solidarity model that
exists in Ukraine for today,
pensions should be linked to citizenship,
not to local budgets
and social assistance.
But the problem was that pensions in 2014
were tied to local budgets.
A very big problem in
receiving the pension
in this situation.
And because in the first
wave of displacement
caused by Russian aggression in 2014,
people of retirement age
faced the need to register
in Ukrainian
government-controlled territory
and undergo humiliating
identification procedures
every few months.
This has, on the one hand,
inflated the real number of IDPs,
forcing people to fictitiously register
for receiving pensions.
And on the other hand, it
has created a situation
in which people of retirement age
had to be identified in
Oshchadbank in Ukraine
every several months,
had to stand in queues
and risked their lives
undergoing humiliating
and meaningless identification procedures
in Ukrainian banks and state institutions.
I want to show you some photos
that I took during one of my studies,
during my study trip.
These are people who are
line up to cross the border
between the Ukrainian-controlled
and non-government-controlled
parts of Luhansk oblast.
So called zero point.
And you see here how it look like
it's usually near 6 people in one line
and very, very long queues.
These people who are waiting
for this crossing the border.
Moreover, it's a other
look on the same position,
moreover, at this checkpoint,
people had to cross,
unfortunately it's not my photo,
the credit for this was mine
but, this I use in open
sources to show you,
how it was during long period.
Now this broken, most are repaired.
Moreover, at this checkpoint,
people had to cross over
the destroyed bridge,
as you can see on this slide.
Try to imagine how it was
for people of retirement age
or elderly people, it's
absolutely horrible situation
for many of them.
This policy of identification processes
especially affected elderly
people with limited mobility
that end up being completely denied
access to pension provision.
It has been estimated that
the number of such people
unable to receive a pension in 2014-2015
was over half a million.
Those who dare to cross
the demarcation line
for the identification
procedure suffered as well.
Research participants estimate
that crossing the border line
could take anywhere from
several hours to several days.
It's really long queues,
it's really much time.
You stay in these queues
and maybe several blocks
something positive but,
it's clear positive moment,
but we see how many businesses
arise around this situation.
Many people who come to these
people staying in queues
and propose, different
kind of help, to buy food,
to staying in the line,
to sell place in the queues,
et cetera, et cetera.
So many businesses, very,
very interesting businesses,
how it's organized here.
But elderly people who died while passing
through the demarcation line,
contribute to the statistics
of civilian victims.
The exact number is unknown
as there is no systematic
calculation of people
who died in queues on both
sides of the demarcation line.
In the pandemic, the
checkpoints were closed
and remained partially closed
until the outbreak of the full-scale war.
In this time the only one option
was to enter through the territory
of the Russian Federation,
but in this case people must pay a fine
for illegally crossing the border.
In 2020, the Ukrainian government
softened this measure and
no fines were imposed.
With the full-scale Russian invasion,
the scope of the occupied
territories has increased.
Today it is no longer just a
problem of Ukrainian citizens
living under occupation
on the Crimean peninsula,
parts of Donetsk and Luhansk oblast.
It is now also a problem for residents
of parts of Kherson, Kharkiv
and Zaporizhzhia regions.
While the procedure for accruing pensions
has been simplified with a bank card,
it is automatically extended
and money is transferred to the account,
the problem for pensioners
in the occupied territories
remains the inability
to receive this money.
The Russian Federation
is blocking Ukrainian
mobile communications
and restricting access
to Ukrainian websites
and services via the Internet
for residents of the occupied territories.
Even if they have a bank card
with money transferred to it,
there is no place to cash it
and it is not possible
to pay with it by phone,
in shops, et cetera.
As a result, people
either have to find ways
to travel to Ukrainian
government-controlled areas,
which is difficult to do
given the hostilities,
or turn to illegal money changers
and lose a significant
percentage of their transfers.
In parallel the banks ensure that there
are no long interruptions
in the use of the card,
at least six months,
as this could indicate the possible death
of the beneficiary of the pension.
In such a case, payments are suspended
until the circumstances are clarified.
However, for the real elderly person
the bureaucratic formula
of "clarification"
means finding difficult ways to travel
to the controlled territory
at the risk of death.
As of today, after heated
discussion about the possibility
of paying pensions to so
called "collaborators"
seem to have subsided.
The Ukrainian state
demonstrates maximum loyalty
in the accrual of pensions
to those who have earned it
according to the solidarity
pension system in Ukraine,
wherever these people are located.
After earlier ambiguous
statements about the population
of the occupied territories,
government officials
now clearly articulate
the people as the state's primary value.
However, the reality of war
and the lack of effective
mechanisms for receiving payments
where all options are
blocked by the aggressor
remain an problem.
Its importance lies in the fact that
for people in the occupied territories
it is often a question of survival,
which affects how they
evaluate the ability
of their own state to protect them.
Why am I highlighting this difference
in situation and policy
in the first and second
stages of Russian aggression?
Because the current policy
of the Ukrainian state
and society towards the victims
of the first wave of Russian aggression,
considerably more humane and
less discriminatory in nature,
was the result of the struggle
for their rights by the first IDPs,
and these complicated public
debates in the country.
But back to the situation in 2014.
Another group seriously
affected by the conflict
was people of pre-retirement age.
People from this category
had little chance
of employment in Ukraine.
Have this very big problem
of age discrimination
and therefore they find themselves
in an extremely tough situation
as a result of forced displacement.
The amount of state aid
for incapacitated persons
was 1000 UAH, it's near $25 monthly,
442 UAH, it's near $20 to $30,
for your comparison, monthly
for those who are able to work.
It's very small sum, it's
very, very small amount.
Such payments could not even
cover basic food expenses,
and were, of course, not
enough to rent housing.
Moreover, this category of people
have been completely invisible
for most of the
international organizations
that help people affected by war.
International organizations mostly worked
with target groups,
on this stage, such as retired people,
people with disabilities,
mothers with little
children, or large family.
But this group of people,
have absolutely lack of help.
And this group remained ignored
by international organizations,
also this category was without
help and stay invisible.
Then, under these
conditions of divided worlds
and separated families,
there are 'unmourned' deaths
that are rarely described
in academic literature.
Before the full-scale Russian invasion,
the average person to enter
the occupied territory
should send a request to the
Security Service of Ukraine
and to receive, within 10 days,
a permit for border crossing.
Important life events, the
death or illness of a relative,
a family reunion, could
accelerate the procedure,
although one still has to spend time
providing official
confirmation of life events.
Also, a decision to let
someone cross the line
was made arbitrarily by
a certain military person
at the checkpoint, on any
side of the demarcation line.
The pandemic have worsened this problem:
people were being denied their
right to cross the border
even when they could confirm purposes
of important life events.
The psychological traumas
of the deaths of loved ones
who are separated by long distances
and unmourned deaths are hard to assess.
The interviews I conducted show that
in the occupied territory, neighbors
got together to bury elderly
people who lived alone,
and their children never
saw their parents dead.
Ordinary people who have found themselves
in extreme circumstances
somehow try to restore the
normality of their lives.
At the same time, they
face certain barriers
both at the level of
reactions in the society
and at the institutional level.
Internally displaced persons
were limited in their rights.
All Ukrainian IDPs had been
deprived of the right to vote
on local government elections until 2020.
IDPs from Crimea are still
defined as non-residents
by the country's bank system,
and have limited access
to banking services.
Prior to the full-scale aggression,
those IDPs who were expecting
to receive state assistance
had to undergo additional
humiliating procedures
of identification and provide
detailed personal information
including answering
questions about their loyalty
to the Ukrainian state.
I signed such document,
I very well remember how it was.
Which ultimately creates a feeling
of their inferior citizenship.
The awareness of all these problems
and the active presence
of IDPs in public debates
gave rise to many new
processes in Ukrainian society.
For example, the demand
for medical services
from more than a million people
has simultaneously led to an accelerated
reform of Ukraine's medical system.
Today's medical system is no longer tied
to the place of registration
of Ukrainian citizens
and medical services are available
everywhere in the country.
The struggle for the political rights
of IDPs has led to the
restoration of the right to vote
not only in presidential
and parliamentary elections
but also in local elections in 2020.
In the Ukrainian context of
war and forced migration,
we see many hybrid volunteering
practices and strategies,
some of which grow into stable
and formalized activities
and some of which fade away,
both because of mitigation
and because of burnout of many people
who very actively involved in
this volunteering activity.
We have this person,
one had to have a very active person
who do everything now in Ukrainian society
but many of them faces this problem.
However, both organized and spontaneous
individual volunteering activities
have a significant impact on society.
For example, the volunteer psychologists
who actively helped people
to overcome stress on the Maidan in 2014
have seen a change in people's attitudes
towards their own mental health
and towards professionals in this field.
And we really now have,
a very big change in Ukrainian society
when people start looking
at their mental health,
start thinking about what to
do with their mental health,
how to change our systematical system
and, given access to different services,
which are connected to this new concept
of mental health in Ukraine.
It's really very important
change in society.
For example in one of
our research we have,
most part it was the
quantitative and qualitative part
of this research about
different kind of practices
connected to the mental health,
and we ask our participants
about how they try to solve their problem
if they feel something
was wrong, what they do,
and only 2.8% of our respondents says
that they come to the professionals
and ask about help in
mental health issues.
It's very low level,
it's really very low level
of working under this issue
but, on the other hand,
we see that these situation
accelerate it's development
and people start thinking about this.
It starts during the Maidan era.
It was very important
that people see that,
it's very difficult for them
to perceive the situation,
to live in this situation.
And many psychologist come to
the Maidan like volunteers,
and start give this help to people
and this accelerate this change
in the culture of mental health,
working on the mental skills issue.
Then...
Let me say several words about this.
So I have to find the (indistinct).
Several words about
volunteering practices,
because I think it's very important.
It's a very important
change in Ukrainian society.
It's led us to present situation.
Euromaidan was a pivotal moment
that strengthened
solidarity among Ukrainians.
While some third sector
groups demonstrated
a transfer of social and human capital
to the situation of mass displacement.
I talk about volunteer,
first of all, in this field,
of helping displaced persons.
Many organizations active today
and providing help to IDPs
were created at the very
beginning of the conflict
based on spontaneous help.
Many IDPs were involved
with these processes,
many IDPs create these volunteering groups
which are help to IDPs in this situation.
For instance, the NGO Donbas
SOS was founded in 2014
as a hotline used for the
quick coordination of help
to the injured people.
Today, the organization
unites 5 coordinators
and around 40 volunteers of the hotline,
also, there is a network
of regional volunteers
in Donetsk, Lughansk, and
15 more regions of Ukraine.
The other organization, Station Kharkiv,
got its name because of the
specificity of its work,
it was at the railway
station where the volunteers
were meeting people, who ran
away from Donetsk and Lughansk
regions affected by war, and
were helping with clothes,
food, searching for accommodations,
and providing legal
consultations for people
forced to rapidly leave their homes
for the indefinite time could have.
Just in the period from
June till December 2014,
Station Kharkiv managed to
find the places of residence
for 30,000 of the displaced people.
A survey of representatives of 138 NGOs,
mainly in cooperation
with my colleague from
Birmingham University, Irina Kuznetsova,
and the previous research
about mental health,
it's same situation,
we had a common project
with Birmingham University
and Ukrainian Catholic University.
In this research we talk
with 138 representatives
of NGOs in Ukraine.
We see that...
Many people who asked about help
received the following
services, you can see here,
it's consultations
regarding employment, 81%,
psychological support, as you see this
is a very big number of
people who receive this,
but usually IDPs do not
ask about this help first.
You need to propose the services
if you want to involve
people in such communication.
Then arrangement of the free time, 67%,
assistance in the renewal
of payment of allowances
and pensions and help with
finding the place of residence.
In most cases NGOs and volunteers
were forced to deal with the
multi-side case management:
as a rule, people, who addressed for help,
had a burden of the whole set of problems
that couldn't be solved separately.
For instance, the lost documents
caused the restrictions
in the search for
accommodation and employment,
and the non-payment of
pensions for many months,
especially in the situation
of the single elderly people,
causes the impossibility
to pay for the dwelling.
It is important to note
that the increase in mutual assistance
is observed not only in
the South-East of Ukraine
near the area of military actions
but also in the other regions.
The complex and flexible
work of volunteers involves
good logistics and
management, builds on trust
and informal connections, makes
use of sponsorship funding,
and is publicly open.
This widespread involvement of people
in charitable activities
creates a feeling of engagement
and solidarity that is crucial
during the war and displacement.
The need to cooperate
with business structures
in one way or another
forms a complex interaction
between them and flexible
volunteer structures,
which often creates
profitable partnerships.
Businesses, in most cases
these are small or medium-sized
businesses, particularly
for this communication
because large businesses usually
work with their charities,
but small and middle businesses
very actively communicate with volunteers.
See volunteer groups as
professionals to whom
they can entrust and delegate social work.
And trust, as the basis
of these relationships,
in turn, encourages
volunteers to worry about
their reputational capital
and strive to make their
activities as open as possible.
It's very important processes.
In a context of social
upheaval and awareness
of the state's considerable
lag in its response,
professionals who entered volunteering
often saw it as an alternative
to the unwieldy state machinery,
as an opportunity to implement projects
that they could not implement
within the already existing structures.
In this case, we can speak
of the powerful reformatory
potential of the volunteer movement,
which through its activity
shapes new models of behavior,
and creates orientation
patterns, and values.
Overall, it provides
a better understanding
of the mechanism of
horizontal mobilization
in Ukrainian society under
conditions of full-scale war
and that unique situation of interaction
between volunteer
groups, the third sector,
business and state structures.
As we can see, Ukrainian
society and representatives
of state structures have
learnt from the situation
in Ukrainian society as a
result of this first stage,
of this first wave of Russian aggression.
In most cases, these are
quite complex processes
that deal with issues of identity,
awareness of oneself
as a political nation,
and the development of a new language
for speaking about what
is going on around us.
However, this situation
of Ukraine's visibility,
of having a position that
sounds in different languages,
is the result of the
discussions and experiences
of this first eight-year period
after the Russian aggression began.
It was the experience of
volunteering during this period
that allowed the volunteer
movement in Ukraine
in the face of full-scale war
to mobilize not in days, but in hours,
and start working to defend the country
and support the population and the army.
The policies towards IDPs in Ukraine
who fled as a result of the February 2022
phase of the war use best
practices regarding IDPs
that were formed during eight years
and be aware of the areas
that were the most problematic
regarding the response to the IDPs' needs.
The areas where the response
was less efficient include:
the lack of affordable and
accessible accommodation
and the lack of social housing.
We still have this problem in our country.
Issues with pensions and benefits.
The lack of recognition of the benefits
of mental health support,
stigmatization of mental health,
and the lack of accessible
mental health support.
Issues with the employment of
people of pre-retirement age.
Given, that globally, the
number of IDPs increased
from about 17 million in 1998
to 59.1 million in 2021,
and that many refugees
experienced protracted
internal displacement
before crossing international borders,
the lessons from Ukraine can be valuable
in addressing similar challenges
in different contexts.
Thank you.
(audience claps)
- [Elena] My name is Elena.
I teach foreign policy
at University of Avon.
Thank you so much for being here
and for all your work.
I know it took quite a risk on your part.
I was wondering if you knew
what proportion of IDPs
have acquired multiple identifications,
like Russian passports,
DNR or LNR passports.
'Cause right now there's
a movement to terminate
Ukrainian citizenship of individuals
that are found to have
multiple identities,
or multiple credentials.
That way, in particular
the case with (indistinct)
That was just recently disclosed.
So there's a move in Ukraine
to quickly terminate,
there's a constitutional process for that.
But I was wondering if that
was part of your research
and if you know,
proportionally, how many IDPs
have actually managed to have
Russian passports and DNR
and if it hurts them, right now,
as they rebuild their lives?
- Thank you very much for this question.
It's really very important to understand
what's going on in these
occupied territories.
As you know the last data,
before the hostile aggression,
it was 700,000 people who
take Russian passports.
But unfortunately I don't know proportion
because I usually use
interviews, not proportions.
What I know about this situation,
it's absolutely no
surprise for many people
who are dealing with
this issue, like IDPs,
they know, in the case of Crimea peninsula
you need two passports.
You need two passports because
without these two passports
you have not any opportunity
to go across the border.
And the same situation
on occupied territory
and what is little bit
problematic for the future
from my point of view, the
people on this territory
have an opportunity to
have five or six passports.
How it's back in Ukrainian context,
first of all, your national
Ukrainian passport,
then we officially have
a right to have two
international passports,
this is three passports.
It's a passport of citizen
of Russian Federation,
the international Russian passport
and of course, passport
of citizen of DNR or LNR.
It's five or six passports for one person,
I think it's a little bit-
- [Elena] Dual citizenship is
not allowed in the Ukraine.
- Yeah?
- [Elena] Dual citizenship is
not allowed in the Ukraine.
You have to renounce one
of your citizenships.
- Yes of course, but
still we are talking about
real practice, not talking about
constitution and about law.
It's real practice.
They all have these six passports
and in different contexts,
they use different passports.
Why I think it's a very
important knowledge about this
because it's a task for the future
how to work with these people
who have these different type of passport.
But in this case we talk about, absolutely
rational acts of these people.
But if you ask about identity,
it's more complicated.
And with my pleasure,
after my presentation,
I will share my text, we
write with Oksana Shevel,
common text about the dynamic
of Ukrainian identities
and it's a very long conversation.
Because we have a different combination.
And we write only about national identity
not about the whole
hierarchy of identities,
only about ethnic and national identities
and you have here so many problems.
When people for example,
ask about their nationality
in Ukraine, they usually
don't know what they mean.
They talk about citizenship
or they talk about ethnicity
because we think this problem
from the Soviet states.
It was a prescription statuses
and in this case when someone from Ukraine
says "I'm Ukrainian", you
don't what the person mean.
It's about ethnicity or
it's about citizenship.
We write about everything in detail.
I will be happy to share this.
It's really very interesting
to look on this dynamic
because if we use quantitative data,
it looks very optimistic,
that we have so many
people who are Ukrainians.
But when we start talking
about their real identity,
how they construct their identity,
absolutely as a feature,
we found a very good way how
to ask people about this.
First of all we ask them,
"Are you thinking about you
in the ethnic or national coordinates?"
And many people says "yes".
Only a small group says "no,
I don't want to talk about me
as representative of some ethnic group."
But these groupings are
very interesting too
because it's the group
which are maybe not agreeing
with official discourses,
but they live in situation
of self-limitation,
self-censorship.
And why they avoid this
answer about their ethnicity.
It's very interesting. Small
group, but very interesting.
Other group, when we talk on the numbers,
it looks very optimistic.
But how can we ask?
We ask first of all, how
do you identify yourself
by ethnic or citizen, et cetera?
And after that, when person use something,
if I ask "Who are you by nationality?"
And the person says, "I'm
a Ukrainian or Russian."
And after this ask "What
does this mean for you?"
And starting from this point,
the person start create
this very interesting construct
of being national identity.
And after that, we try
to systematize all these
version of national identities.
It's really very interesting
but when you read everything
I understand that it's not so easy
like it's look like, when we
ask only about nationality.
Thank you.
- [Isabella] Hi I'm Isabella.
I teach political science here.
So my question actually builds on this,
which is about the use of language.
So, what language do they use?
Not just by the internally
displaced persons,
but by the officials, and
both by the volunteers
and by the state (indistinct).
As you observe their interactions.
- You ask me about language as a country
or about language for research?
- [Isabella] No, language
when they talk to each other,
when they interact.
- In Ukraine.
As I says, we really now perceive
a very rapid Ukrainization in the country.
It's really very hard to
separate how to identify,
their, not answers, but us in this case.
For example, I come back to this idea
that I work, not with numbers,
but I work with senses,
when I talk with people.
What's very interesting for me,
when I talk with my
interlocutor about this issue,
how he perceives
Russian-speaking people now
in the context of full scale aggression.
He says me, that it's
very important for him
the person start from something,
from small sentences
in Ukrainian language.
Because he needs this for
identification processes.
And after that they know,
that these persons are ours,
it's not others.
And after that, many people
start talking Russian language,
but now many of them try to
turn the language of Ukrainian.
But it usually take time.
It usually takes time.
It's not possible to start
talking in other languages
but all Ukrainians are bilingual.
We have not in Ukraine, people
who know only one language.
All Ukrainians bilingual.
It's a question of practices.
Some part of Ukraine have practices
to use Russian in everyday life.
Some other parts of Ukraine,
very actively use Ukrainian
in everyday life.
But in our interview we see
a very interesting moment
which show how these
protests started after 2014.
For example, I have an
interview with a person
who voluntarily joined
to military formation
on the territory of
Donetsk and Lugansk oblask.
When I ask him about the language usage,
he says, it's very
important how he related it,
"unfortunately Russian."
(audience laughs)
This "unfortunately Russian" shows you
the perception of the situation
and wishes to use the language.
In 2018, I conducted research
in four oblast of Ukraine,
it's Donetsk and Lugansk oblast,
and the Zaporozhye and Kherson oblast.
Now you see it's a battlefield in Ukraine.
And of course, we ask about identity
and we ask about language usage
and what I found during this research.
Unfortunately, it's not possible
to quickly find this here,
but if I'm not mistake,
when I ask about this,
people who live in Donetsk
and Lugansk oblast,
most of them, near 40% of them,
says that their native
language is Ukraine.
But when I ask, what language
do you use on the work,
what language do you use
in everyday communication,
it's usually Russian language.
But here we see a desire to be Ukrainians.
We come back to this
funny, "unfortunately"
because it's the same.
(people speak at the same time)
- [Audience Member] Sorry,
what about the children
are they bilingual from an early age,
the curriculum is bilingual?
- Especially children,
especially young person,
because during 30 years in the Ukraine,
we have this soft Ukrainization.
For example, before 2014 in
my native city in Donetsk,
I read a lecture only
in Ukrainian language
and all our greeting was in Ukrainian.
It was a state policy
and my young generation
who study in Ukrainian school,
study in Ukrainian university,
have good practices to
use Ukrainian language.
For many young people in
Ukraine, it's no problem
to switch from Ukrainian to Russian.
But not now, because
unfortunately Russian.
Because it's political reaction now.
Many Ukrainians know Russian very well
but now they stop use language
if they could change
the language in speech.
- [Audience Member] So there's no coercion
on the part of the Ukrainian state?
So those that you observe, (indistinct).
Was there pressure
towards Ukrainian persons?
- No, I think it's a battle
for maybe these people
and displaced persons.
It's not a pressure.
It's a process where you need to integrate
this normal communication in the state.
I think it's a conversation
about the right of people
to talk in their native language.
And for many Ukrainians,
Ukrainian is native language.
But during long time we live
in Russian-speaking environment.
I think now, in my country,
we have these very important
discussions between these
two different speaking group
in Ukraine, how to have this compromise
and according to the understanding
of the rights of this country.
I think it's a bold push
of everybody in Ukraine
to start using the
Ukrainian in every day life.
- [Marci] Maybe I'll
just ask one question,
take advantage of my position.
Since we have a couple more minutes.
So, you had also talked
with pro-Russian people
in the Donbas years ago
and with the rebels,
what did you learn?
What did you understand
about their position
from having spoken with them?
This is the point of view
that's so hard for us to get.
Even now, I was pleading
with my friend Pablo Humanjek
who's a young Polish
journalist, who covered the war
in the Donbas and now
he's covering it again.
He's very good at talking to people,
he's like this young Polish guy.
And I said, "Pablo,
can't you get interviews
with Russian soldiers?
If they're gonna talk to anyone."
And he's like, "No, even I can't do it.
I just can't talk to them."
But what did you learn about
how people were thinking?
- Thank you very much for this question.
It's a very complicated question for me.
I studied a lot, but I have
not answered this question.
Clearly I have not
a clear and simple
answer to this question.
We work with motivation, for example,
people who voluntarily join
this military formation,
from the side of DPR and LPR.
It was horrible research for me
because I needed to talk
with people who are my enemy.
Then I try to analyze the motivation
and try to understand
what their motivation?
Why they join this military
formation from other side?
I think it's really very
important to understand
that here it's not possible
to have a simple answer
to this question and many of them
have a long life strategy.
Many of them was
unsuccessful during this life
and this forms maybe negative perception
of Ukrainian statehood which
resulted them in their choice.
Then I work with these
flows of information
and how people perceive the information.
All historians know how it's look.
It's a very simple for understanding this.
For example, during this
initial stage in 2014
and 2015 all people who
live on the territory
of DPR and LPR have
free access to internet.
But when you have this
free access to internet
why you not diversify the information,
why you don't feed the other sources?
No, many people don't
feed and how it's look,
it's usually look in a very simple way.
You start with some text and
see that it's opposite to you,
you will not agree with this text
and you close these sources
and start to seek the other sources
which are very close to your perception
of the real situation.
And after that, we see how this audience
encapsulated during this stage
and the distance between
them become very big
and they oriented to absolutely
other model of perception
of situation, model of
behavior, et cetera.
So many reasons.
So many reasons and we
see from the point of view
of childhood, from the point
of view they are successful
when they start their education.
For example, it was
very interesting for me,
many of our interlocutors from
that side of the conflict,
says about the educational strategy
like very specific, for
example, it's combination
of ideotechnic and culturology.
It's the person trying to find themselves
in absolutely different spheres
and as a result have not any good result
for their successful life,
for example, in this phase.
It's really so many, so many moments
which are important to
understand in how it's working.
- [Audience Member] Hi, I'm
Elian, based doing research
from the Refugees Study
Center in Oxford in the UK.
I wanted to ask, because
you were talking a bit about
younger people who were choosing not to
take IDP status, I think you
said, because of some stigma,
or not wanting to be
a burden on the state,
I wonder if you could
explain more about why
they felt that that status
was something stigmatized.
And also about what they do instead,
how they would identify instead?
Or how they would go
about making themselves?
- Thank you very much.
It was one of the set of IDPs
which was very interesting
to understand and why they
choose such strategies
when they relocated.
Many young people and I
think it's main difference
between young and old generation.
Many young people haven't experienced
how to run the house, before
their forced relocation
and they not be afraid of
the future in this case.
They come from Donetsk
and Lugansk region to Kyiv
and start their new career.
But while we talk about this strategy
how to avoid the stigmatization
because it's the
beginning of the conflict.
Many people in Ukraine
don't understand clearly what's happened.
And I talk about this situation
on the state-level called
anti-terroristic operation.
And it's created a situation in society
when IDPs perceived like collaborators,
like people who are
invite Russian soldiers
to Ukrainian land, et cetera, et cetera.
And why young people have this opportunity
and try to avoid to
receive these IDP statuses
because of these ambiguous
perception in the society.
It really was much more easy for them
because they have previous experience
how to weave his own pants,
how to lengthen the trousers.
Many IDPs still these
document of those IDP statuses
when they need to have
this help from the state.
But then it's become
the next stage, all of us
need to have this document,
that we have status of IDPs
because of other reasons.
For example, when I try to
do something in official way,
my passport, it's not enough
for solving many problems,
I need to have this additional document
about my IDP status.
But now it's totally changed.
Now our state talk about
these canceling of IDP status.
But on the other hand, we
still need these statuses
because its still about
the help of the people
who are proceed the war,
who need the state help.
It's a question of discussion in Ukraine.
It's like how to be with the status.
What it means now to be an IDP
and how to deal with this
status in Ukrainian society now.
- [Caroline] My name is Caroline,
I'm a second year masters student
in Russian States program.
I have a question about the perceptions
of Ukrainians abroad.
I was in Poland over
the summer helping out
at a reception point for
refugees from the Ukraine.
I've been in Kyiv before.
And you know, you saw just
anecdotally on the Kyiv metro,
you'd see all these signs
advertising work in Poland.
Someone told me before I came to Poland
that before the war a lot
of Uber drivers in Poland
were Ukrainian men and
then when the full scale
aggression began, that people left
and that created a shift
demographically in Poland,
who was working, who was not.
Have you seen any, in terms of,
and then just walking around,
a significant outpouring
of support for Ukrainian refugees
and how people put aside businesses,
their livelihoods,
to devote significant
portions of their time
to helping people coming in.
What have you noticed in terms
of the evolution of the perceptions
of Ukrainians abroad over
time and how that's evolved?
- Thank you.
It's about current situation.
Thank you very much.
I know much more about
the situation in Germany
because I lived in Germany
and helped many refugees
from Ukraine during this period.
And very involved in these
volunteering procedures
in Germany, I know how it's organized
and how it looks in Germany.
Perception was positive.
Of course in Poland too.
For me, it was unexpected level of support
from Poland society.
It's really very high level of support.
We need to know that it's not state,
first of all, support from
the level of the society,
Polish society.
Polish people are very actively
reacting to the situation.
It's my personal situation,
in the day when full scale war started
I was in Berlin, with my youngest son,
and I went by feet across the border
from Shehyni, it's oblast to Poland.
It was a first night after
the starting of full-scale war
and people from Poland waiting for us
on the Polish side of the border.
It's first night.
They come to the border and pick up people
and help with any question.
I think it's very high level of support.
It still exists in Polish society.
They actively involved.
Of course, we're still faced
with some negative perception
which we inherited from
the previous period.
But it's something very human.
We usually have different people
who reacted in different way.
But if you look on this situation at all,
I think we have unprecedented level
of help and support in Europe.
- [Audience Member] Thanks
for your presentation.
I have a question in terms
of the joining the army,
so a younger section of the IDPs.
In just a comparison between
the younger section of IDP
and the rest of the people.
Young people in Ukraine
joining the war after 2014
are joining the army after 2014
and also more recently
do you see some sort of
variation in terms of,
for example, bureaucratic
hurdles for them to join the army
because of the identity, various,
and secondly, it's also what's
their intrinsic motivation
in terms of serving the state.
Have you seen any evidence
or insight about it?
- Unfortunately I have not
any research about this.
It's maybe only my,
my feeling, my understanding of this.
When we work with this motivation in 2014,
because we have these two group,
the one side the people who
support this DPR and LPR
and on the other side, of
course, Ukrainian volunteers.
And it was really very interesting to work
on this motivation and many of them who
voluntarily involved in such fighting,
again in this first stage of the war,
have a very clear description
of their identity.
What I mean when I start
talking about this?
In this case, when you are
not sure in your identity,
when I ask you about
your identity, you start
a very long and very detailed description
how it's possible to identify you
in different situations,
et cetera, et cetera.
If people sure in their
identity, it's usually very clear
and very simple answer, "I'm Ukrainian."
"I'm citizen of Ukraine, it's
my country, it's my duty."
It was very interesting to
compile this description
of identity from these
people who supported other
and people who joined this
Ukrainian volunteer formation.
And I think it's the
same situation maybe now,
in present day, when many young men,
not young only, not only men in Ukraine,
voluntarily join army.
And I think it's a very strong motivation
which argument of model
of political nation.
I talk about this today,
they think now Ukrainians
really perceive themselves
like political nation.
It's a very important role.
And all Ukrainians understand
that we are talking about
our future in this situation.
It's our duty to save our future.
I think it's very strong
and main motivation
for many our people who now join army.
- [Marci] Please join me.
I want to thank Prof. Mikheieva.
I think there's still food out there
so I'm going to do my Jewish mother thing
and encourage everyone to eat
your protein and vegetables.
Briefly in response to your question
and for the non-Slavicists here.
There is a novel that
recently has been translated
to English, by one of Oksana's colleagues,
Volodymyr Rafeyenko, from Donetsk,
he was an internally displaced person.
He moved in 2014, a great novelist
who had been writing in
Russian, learned Ukrainian
and wrote this novel "Mondegreen"
about the experience of
being a displaced person
and reconstructing a self
in a language that was his
but wasn't quite his.
And it was wonderfully
translated into English
by my colleague, Mark
Andryczyk, at Columbia
and it's just come out.
If you want to commune
with that experience
from the point of view of literary fiction
I encourage to do that.
Students please free to hang around
and talk to Prof. Mikheieva,
you can see she's very
friendly and approachable.
And please join me in thanking her.
(audience applauds)